The James Webb Space Telescope being developed
by NASA is set to be one the most exciting
space observatories ever developed!, with
totally novel technologies and instruments
that will give us new insights into our universe.
But unfortunately, its completion and launch
has been delayed.
Again.
What’s goin’ on?
The initial completion window for the James
Webb Space Telescope, or JWST, was supposed
to be between 2007 and 2011.
There were some pretty severe budget and schedule
issues, resulting in a 2011 overhaul of the
project that set a new completion date for
October of 2018.
That turned out to be a little too optimistic,
so they pushed it back to May of 2020, and
now here we are with another new hopeful finish
line of March, 2021.
This telescope is the successor to the Hubble
Space Telescope, so this is the kind of telescope
we send out into space.
All by itself!
This is where some of the complexities start.
Once launched, the JWST will be out of reach
of the NASA team completely, unreachable even
by robotic missions.
This makes it significantly more complicated
than the Hubble which we can service.
After JWST heads out into the great unknown,
that’s it, so we’ve kinda gotta get all
its features right before we say goodbye.
And this is kinda hard, because James Webb
is most complicated space observatory we’ve
ever built.
It’s huge, it has be super sensitive, and
most of its diagnostics are brand new.
For example, its sunshield, which keeps the
telescope at the ideal temperature (below
50 Kelvin) is the size of a tennis court and
consists of five individual layers.
It was actually a small tear in this key piece
that was part of the most recent delay.
And then there’s the telescope’s primary
mirror, called the Optical Telescope Element,
or OTE.
This gathers the light coming into the telescope
from space so the other scientific instruments
on board can measure it.
The OTE is exciting--and difficult--because
a mirror that detects these kinds of signals
needs to be large, but a mirror this large
has never been launched into space before.
In fact, it’s almost 7 times larger than
Hubble’s mirror, but NASA has engineered
it to still be lighter than the Hubble mirror
per unit area, so that’s a big innovation.
AND it’s super strong.
AND..it folds!
This gold-plated mirror actually folds up
so it can fit into the launch rocket, and
then it will unfurl once in space.
It also just looks REALLY cool too, like a
giant, shiny golden honeycomb.
To round it all off, most of the scientific
instruments on board are totally new.
Some will observe light on the visible and
infrared spectra, trying to capture objects
and events that are too distant or too old
to be observed by other instruments.
One of the machines needs a cryocooler to
keep it at a frosty 7 Kelvin so it works properly.
And keep in mind, we have to make sure all
of these new and exciting scientific tools
will function and transmit data properly for
5-10 years after JWST launches, because once
it’s out there...we can never touch it again.
But if we can accomplish all of this, we hope
it will offer us back here on earth never-before-seen
resolution of space and will help us see traces
of some of the most distant events and objects
in our universe--like the very creation of
galaxies, stars, and planets.
It’ll basically be like looking back in
time.
Its launch could mark a new era in astrophysics.
That is, when it ever gets off the ground.
Hey, maybe the JWST is delayed NOW, but if
you're watching from the future we hope you’re
still subscribed to Seeker to be keeping up
with all the things we’re learning from
it.
Like this video over here about about how
NASA uses origami for it’s engineering.
Also FYI, the JWST isn’t just a NASA job--the
Canadian and European Space agencies are also
in on the project, because let’s be real,
space brings us all together.
Thanks for watching Seeker, I’m Maren.